nouveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir les enfants beaux soirs bz
ce soir nous allons faire de grandes
choses ou les cheveux bon ben j'ai bien
peur que nounours est apporté son livre
de cuisine
[Musique]
bonsoir ma petite pas preneur tiens pas
à livres d'histoire non mon livre de
recettes de cuisine ont maintenant c'est
nous qui faisons de la cuisine ce soir
elle nous n'avons pas besoin de te
fameuse recette vient voir nicolas nikon
a dénoncé mme à ce que ça sent bon
je suis un petit garçon de bonne figure
qui eux mobio le bonbon et les
confitures suivant foulée montanay jeu
sera bien les mots j'ai la bonne
aventure hockey le rebond aventureux
c'est à confiture euro ne touchent pas
nous allons assieds toi et regarde on le
bon fromage mais qui n'a fait qu'il est
de son ménage ballade en fa majeur celui
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a fait là dessous
et l'âge à médor voile intégral fromage
salade du monde de l'ère bush ce fromage
ne touchent pas gros gourmand mais jure
ça ne fait rien gd pintendre déranger
des blanches font 4 pourrait tout
mademoiselle retourner voilà deux sous
ben moi seul
au moins tu as faim voilà de pain
montanari comme temps panaris comme dans
la sauce brune aux canaries tampon
panaris tonnes dont un an
mais pas devin il veut paltrow du loup
mais c'était pour rire les noces ne
plante pas regarde tout ça c'est pour
toi as il faut faire les petites
marionnettes massivement emprunté pour
les sauver ainsi font font font les
petites marionnettes asif offense au
premier tour et puis s'en vont à la
meinau ses quotas ce que vous m'avez
gâter les enfants
merci de nuit les petits faites de beaux
draps
[Musique]
où
bonne nuit les enfants à voici notre
nounours tu es bien chargé pas trop
rares du rocker du tout ça c'est pour
nous on s'en va j'ai une de ses fins en
route
bonne nuit
et merci
merci épaules de nuit
ah ah
auj
oh
[Applaudissements]